cette norme notre heure tourne une fois
rendre la justice avant midi c'est
pourquoi je prendrais maintenant au
procureur de la république général des
proches de monnoir procédé au
réquisitoire
[Musique]
eh bien monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les jurés public lyrique
alors que l'astre lunaire glissait sous
les étoiles s'attendre blondeur opaline
oui oui j'avais clair de lune pas un
ange m'est apparue en songe cette nuit
il était d'une blondeur et tran thi
blond comme la lune c est toute la bonté
du monde se lisait dans son regard clair
il s'est assis au bord de mon lit et
dans un sourire infiniment d'où cet ange
mahdi gars forme de l'anus clément soum
acquis rika zaraï lapidaire et boum
c'est à dire soit clément avec pierre
delanoë
que celui qui n'a jamais écrit de
chansons pour rika zaraï lui jette la
première pierre
puis lange s'est lentement élevé puis il
a ôté son ample robe blanc oui enfin la
presse ma vie toujours est il que cette
visite céleste m'a fortement
impressionné monsieur le président en
ébranlant mon intime conviction qui est
aussi la devise de ce tribunal
ils ne sentent us dégueulasse ou
m'excuse prématuré c'est à dire tout
innocent est présumé coupable
je sentais en moi monté le doute et
l'incertitude et si delanoë n'était pas
coupable pensais-je comment faire pour
avoir quand même sa tête
c'est alors que le message abscons de
l'ange gabriel
car si c'était tel car séries télé
c'est alors que le message abscons de
l'ange gabriel me parut tout un coup
plus clair le ciel demander la clémence
du procureur pour pierre delanoë
parce que cet homme mesdames et
messieurs les jurés avant de se vautrer
dans la fange hérétiques de la chanson
païenne cet homme a été un homme de bien
puisqu'il a été inspecteur des finances
comme le dirait si bien d'abeilles aussi
fields le fleur préférée de ce tribunal
d'exception quelqu'un qui a été
fonctionnaire aux impôts ne peut pas
être tout à fait mauvais autre
circonstance atténuante pierre delanoë a
écrit le texte de la chanson de goldorak
elle monde le sait pas les mamans qui je
le sais sont nombreuses à nous écouter à
cette heure joyeuse où la féminité
maternelle trouve son plein
épanouissement dans la préparation de la
bouffe les mamans indices connaissent
bien la haute valeur pédagogique de ce
goldorak
quoi de plus charmant en effet que le
spectacle réconfortant de ces millions
de bambins bavent d'abrutissement devant
les aventures crétine au spatial de cet
arrêt métalloïdes petits-enfants de
france regardez et goldorak
certes c'est con mais ça laisse pas la
gueule de bois et contrairement aux avis
ça conduit pas forcément à l'héroïne et
qu'elle est belle votre chanson goldorak
monsieur delanoë qu'elle est belle
je ne sais pas pourquoi cette mélodie
nous fait penser à chopin mais le temps
passe et je m'aperçois que je me trouve
que des circonstances atténuantes pour
l'accusé c'est qui va encore me mettre
en froid avec le portugais d'en face
quel est le pourrait vous reprocher vos
initiales pierre delanoë
mais ce serait mesquin d'une part et
cite aussi les miennes je pourrais vous
reprocher d'être né tout de suite après
l'armistice de 1918 c'est une façon
habile d'éviter de faire la guerre on
pourrait vous taxez d'apologie du
proxénétisme
effectivement de l'opéra daran à la
chanson de maquereaux n'y a qu'un pas
et bien non monsieur delanoë je vous
accuse d'autres choses
je vous accuse d'exercice illégal de la
médecine vous êtes un rebouteux
diabolique et j'en ai pour preuve
l'article de mademoiselle mireille par
ayew qui écrit dans le parisien libéré
du 12 août dernier
pierre delanoë a remis les choses de la
chanson française à leur place bien sûr
depuis que sheila a mué on se doutait
que la chanson française avec une
descente d'organes
et bien justement mesdames et messieurs
les jurés y en aurait terminé que
demandé je demande qu'on lui coupe
quelque chose
[Musique]
on y verra plus clair
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est non